according to news reports black lives
matter is going bankrupt despite having
raised a whopping 90 million dollars in
just one year following the death of
George Floyd BLM is now reportedly eight
and a half million dollars in the hole
and might have to shudder operations
which sounds great except like so many
news stories it isn't true
the numbers are all true
but the story is not true BLM is not
going bankrupt
it's just distributed all the money
the founders got their Mansions the
cronies got their payouts the operatives
milked Corporate America for a ton of
cash and now it's likely to close up
shop which gives BLM the added benefit
of closing its crooked books and
reducing the scrutiny that it's
currently under
black lives matter was never an
institution for the long haul it was
always just an opportunistic Shakedown
racket which has now dispersed its
bribes to its network of gangsters and
is now poised to disappear just in time
for the operatives to spin up a new scam
to score cash for scaring citizens as we
head into the next presidential election
right on time the more things change the
more they stay the same I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show we are moving
into a Brave New World and actually
there's a a video going around from the
Kardashians I've never watched an
episode of the Kardashian show but Khloe
Kardashian gives a really important
perspective on surrogacy pregnancy and
surrogacy that is frankly
it's more perceptive than even many
pro-lifers have talked about so we'll
get to that in just a second first
though
speaking of these payoffs
Bud Light
poor Bud Light down what is it 15 bill
in market cap right now
Bud Light apparently
still has not learned it's lesson
because Bud Light according to reports
is
still going to sponsor three Pride
events daily wire reported on this
yesterday
Bud Light is listed as the sponsor of
the Cincinnati Pride Parade a Planned
Parenthood in the Cincinnati Children's
Hospital which transes little kids are
both also listed for that one in St
Louis
where transheiser bush is headquartered
they are a presenting sponsor the
presenting sponsor of the St Louis Pride
Parade
the rainbow sponsorship tier which is
below the presenting sponsor tier
requires 25 Grand in in donations to the
LGBT LMNOP gestapo so who knows how much
transheiser bush is paying there and
then they're also listed as a diamond
sponsor of Stonewall Columbus which
organizes and hosts the annual Columbus
Ohio Pride Parade
it's not an accident it's not an oopsie
Daisy it's not some Rogue VP of
marketing named Alyssa whatever her name
is going rogue and don't worry we've put
her on leave so you you normal people
who don't want us to trans your kids you
can buy Bud Light again no this was a
decision made from the top not just the
top of Bud Light
the top of transheiser bush the top of a
b inbev because we know I had a long
Twitter Thread about this the other day
that ABN Bev is totally on board with
ESG and with garm and with all of the
global
multi-industry standards that say that
these companies are going to back the
pride movement
and transgenderism and all the other
sexual radicalism in a way I feel bad
for this marketing executive Alyssa
hershenfeld or something like that
because she took the fall
for an issue that was obviously directed
from the top down and so they haven't
learned their lesson which means
that conservatives need to keep up the
pressure
this is this is working we have
seriously damaged Bud Light
we may have destroyed Bud Light
permanently as the best-selling beer in
America you're seeing this a little bit
now with Target
is getting slammed they're also losing a
ton of money right now because Target
decided to sell a satanic designed
transgender uh bathing suits where you
can tuck tuck men's body parts into
women's bathing suits Pride merch for
children all sorts of stuff so
conservatives are saying okay we're not
shopping at Target anymore this is
really damaging them this is the the
most momentum I've ever seen
conservatives have heading into pride
month
and so we've got to keep up the pressure
Matt articulated this very well the
other day but it's been a
motivation and a goal that we've been
talking about for some months now which
is
we need to make that rainbow flag
absolutely toxic in Corporate America
and among politicians it has to be toxic
the pride flag is at least as offensive
to me as any other flag on Earth
it's not even just about the weird sex
stuff pride is the symbol of the
deadliest of the seven deadly sins it is
the queen of all vices it is the sin
that made Satan fall like lightning from
heaven and kicked Adam and Eve out of
the Garden of Eden it is just pure evil
okay if you live your life according to
Pride
and all of the subsidiary sins and vices
that go along with that you're not going
to flourish you're not going to have a
good life and a society that exalts
Pride above every virtue
that makes a virtue out of the deadliest
of the seven deadly sins is not going to
be a good society and so any
establishment that it's flying that flag
out out its window you should not
frequent that establishment any
politician who waves the pride flag as a
matter of his campaign you should not
vote for that politician you should not
donate a penny to that politician I know
that I'm preaching to the choir but we
need a little bit of encouragement here
I think because a lot of people thought
well we can't boycott every company and
sure you can't boycott every company but
you can Target you can seriously damage
the profit margins of companies that are
embracing this stuff in a particular way
we've done it a lot of people thought it
wasn't possible and then
Bud Light Lost a ton of market cap and
then Target is is in shambles and it's
scrambling to make sense of this
the LGBT movement went too far over the
past few years when they've tried to
trans the kids
public opinion is overwhelmingly on our
side we still have a decent amount of
economic power the political class at
least in some corners of the right is
finally following suit keep up that
pressure that pride flag should be
understood by everybody in this culture
as being absolutely political poison the
people who fly that flag in politics and
Corporate America should be made
anathema we got to talk to each other
about it when you want to talk to each
other you got to check out pure talk
right now go to puretalk.com Knowles do
you remember the last time you got a
free phone started out feeling great
right and then came the Hefty activation
fees the four line requirements and of
course that binding contract Pure Talk
is giving you a free 5G Samsung Galaxy
phone without the feeling that you've
been duped when you switch to Pure talks
unlimited talk and text data plan that
comes with a mobile hotspot you will get
a 5G Samsung Galaxy for free that's
right unlimited everything at a fraction
of the price of Verizon ATT or T-Mobile
here's another thing you'll be on
America's Most Dependable 5G Network how
do I know because I am a customer make
the switch to Pure Talk the cell phone
Wireless company and I'm proud to stand
behind because one they have a great
service and two they're proud to stand
behind our mission at the daily wire
pure talks us-based customer service
team will help you make the switch in as
little as 10 minutes and you can even
keep your phone number go to
puretalk.com
for your free Samsung Galaxy when you
sign up for unlimited talk text and
unlimited data puretalk.com Knowles Pure
Talk Wireless for Americans buy
Americans
you think the Brave New World is in the
future
that's what I thought I thought the
Brave New World oh in the future
things are going to get really bad that
we're going to start living in a
dystopia
the future is already kind of here
isn't it that's already happening and
maybe that's one eccentric weirdo guy
and maybe we're seeing reports this this
is a really disturbing report
100 lab grown babies in five years this
is out of the Guardian Japanese
researchers are on the cusp of creating
human eggs and sperm that can be grown
in a fake womb producing human sperm and
eggs in the lab is known as in vitro
gamito Genesis it's already been
achieved in mice scientists say it's
possible in humans in five years
meaning that you could take any kind of
cell from any kind of people you take a
skin cell from two dudes and create a
baby and then have through this
artificial synthetic sperm and egg make
a baby
who in some cases would have no parents
meaning yes maybe you get two dudes or
two chicks or one dude and who knows
coming in and using some of their cells
to do it or you just make the baby on a
computer you say okay this is the kind
of sperm we're gonna have this the kind
of egg we're gonna have and you make a
baby that doesn't have parents and this
is being heralded as an exciting new
breakthrough we're right on the cusp
five years away
in other words
the headline is scientists so excited
scientists looking forward to producing
a human being with the intention of
depriving that human being of a mother
and a father
for no other reason than to satisfy
their unmorbid curiosity and to make
themselves into gods and we're supposed
to celebrate this
since
modernity kicked in
after the Scientific Revolution after
the enlightenment
there have been a lot of technological
advancements but there's been a complete
collapse in ethics
theology morality and philosophy there's
been a collapse we don't know anything
anymore we don't know who we are we
don't know what a man is we don't know
what a woman is and that's a very
dangerous combination that's very very
toxic
because we end up in Jurassic Park
Jurassic Park is in fact
in many ways about this problem it's
also about big scary dinosaurs running
around but it's in many ways about this
problem that's the deeper message which
is what will happen in society if we
achieve technical knowledge such that we
can do
the sorts of things we've never been
able to do before
but we
lose the moral and philosophical and
Theological
wisdom to to understand when we
shouldn't do certain things and it's not
just off in the future this kind of
stuff is happening right now
I've got to start watching the
Kardashian show I guess the only reality
show I've ever really liked is Jersey
Shore because I just know those people I
grew up with those kind of people uh and
I've got to start watching the
Kardashian show this was one of the most
serious and nuanced discussions of the
issue of surrogacy that I've seen
anywhere on television and it came from
Khloe Kardashian
do you feel less connected this is not
easy I definitely like buried my head in
the sand during that pregnancy that I
didn't digest what was happening and so
I think when I went to the hospital I
really think that was the first time
that really registered and has nothing
to do with the baby it's just you're
like okay we're having a baby and this
is my son and I'm taking him home with
me I definitely was in a State of Shock
I think from my entire experience
in general
don't stop don't stop I felt really
guilty that like this woman just had my
baby and you're just I take the baby and
then I go to another room and you're
sort of separated like I felt it's such
a transactional experience because it's
not about him
[Music]
I wish someone was honest about
surrogacy
and the difference of it but it doesn't
mean it's bad or good it's still great
okay and then there it is right at the
end
that's the required
endorsement of the sexual Revolution and
all this Progressive insanity
but the entire segment the whole
argument
says no surrogacy is obviously terrible
there's obviously something deeply wrong
with this
and here's why
and here's how I felt it and here's how
I bet the surrogate mother felt it and
here's why it's so wrong for the baby
because because procreation is supposed
to be about the baby the only person to
be said to have any real rights in that
is the baby is not us but I've had
trouble connecting with my child now as
a result of this I feel like I just
discarded this woman I just rented this
poor woman's womb and I throw her at and
I take the baby it didn't occur to me
that the natural process of pregnancy
would would get me prepared physically
and mentally and spiritually to have a
baby I didn't have any of that I just
drove to the hospital one day I just
realized oh my goodness I'm having a
baby and it's been so so hard and I wish
people were honest about how terrible
surrogacy is
but I mean it's great though but no but
it's really it's great though I know I
have to say that because I'm a
mainstream figure on television
but
it's not
it's not great it's obviously wrong and
I see why people
have been tempted to do it I see why
it's 10 why all sorts of
Temptations exist people are tempted
toward things that are bad because it
seems like there's some goodness there
or because they feel a little bit
desperate or because they're constrained
in their lives and so I get it I
understand the temptation to surrogacy
but good ends
the good end of having a baby
do not justify immoral means
and when we engage in immoral means I
mean you see this throughout the Old
Testament
some of the greatest figures in the Old
start to cut corners and start to fall
into Temptations and start to say oh
well I can't have a child with my wife
or I'm gonna have a child with her
handmade
we're okay I can't I can't get this
victory that I want okay I'm going to
cut a corner over here and it never
works out things begin to spiral out of
control we are simply not smart enough
to be able to account for all of the
externalities to account for all of the
unintended consequences of these sorts
of things we think we are we flatter
ourselves in rationalist modernity that
we can we can reason through every
single little thing in fact we're far
less capable of reasoning through all of
these consequences than human beings
were even four or five hundred years ago
we we don't possess even the
sophistication that people had then and
then they had a much healthier dose of
humility
and recognized that
it might seem fine on a sheet of paper
to say okay I'm gonna I'm gonna rent
this poor woman's womb she's going to
deal with all the difficult parts of
pregnancy and then I'm gonna go pick up
my baby at the baby store but gosh it
just seems so transactional and isn't
there something deeper to human life
than mere transaction mod modernity
liberalism tells us
that we're all basically just consumers
we're all just economic creatures in a
Marketplace and I pay you for this and
you give me that good in service and the
left believes that and even the right
large swads of the right believe that
but that's not true you can't just make
every
aspect of Our Lives into some economic
transaction this is what the great
conservative Edmund Burke warned about
when he warned of the economists
officers and calculators who had taken
over the world these are not merely
economic transactions especially when
we're talking about the relationship
between a mother and her child listen to
Khloe Kardashian she makes a good
argument
as things are falling apart by the way
folks
we are going to need to prepare for what
could come and that's why you got to
check out my Patriot Supply right now go
to
preparewithnolls.com I love that URL
it's difficult to trust anything or
anyone these days if you've been paying
attention to current events at all these
past few years you know that you need to
be prepared for anything reality is you
might not be able to find food when the
next disaster strikes right now my
Patriot Supply is knocking 200 off their
popular three-month emergency food kit
go to preparewithknolls.com grab this
special deal before it ends your
three-month emergency food kit provides
over 2 000 calories each day for optimal
strength and energy in stressful
situations enjoy a wide variety of
breakfasts lunches dinners drinks and
snacks do not put off your preparation
any longer tomorrow might be too late
go to prepare with knowles.com save 200
on the three month food kit you will
also get free and fast shipping on your
order prepare with knowles.com that is
prepare with Knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s.com head on over there
right now
you know with Father's Day coming up
I've been thinking about how grateful I
am that my father did not become a woman
for all of his many accomplishments the
greatest accomplishment might be that he
gave me my life at least from my
perspective and he couldn't have done
that if he had become a chick without
him I wouldn't be here
while that might be a strange thing to
say we live in strange times so we
shouldn't take the simplest gifts for
granted show your appreciation gratitude
for your dad making the Bold choice to
remain the gender that he was assigned
at Birth with a gift from Jeremy's
Racers right now they have a 30 off sale
on select bundles and razor starter kits
they're 100 woke free and unashamed to
celebrate manliness so this Father's Day
do not just give him any gift give him
Jeremy's razors the gift that says thank
you Dad for being and staying a man
thank you for transitioning go to
jeremy'sraisers.com today to take 30 off
our razors and not 100 off your genitals
if that line still gets me when I read
it and whoever the copywriter is
certainly deserves a raise
speaking of Technology we're seeing
election interference from Big Tech
already
and it's not Trump getting kicked off
Twitter and it's not DeSantis getting
kicked off YouTube or something it is my
friend
the fake ramaswami
being kicked off of
LinkedIn which is I have to say
the most Vivek social network to be
kicked off of that is so I've mentioned
that uh Vivek and I know each other from
college I was an undergraduate when he
was at the law school we were in similar
kind of clubs and organizations to to
one another
um and and so at the time we we didn't
know each other very well during college
but he had a reputation as being just
very type a very meticulous very very
intelligent very serious and ambitious
and successful and he obviously has
proven that he sold a company for a ton
of money he uh attended the top Law
School in the country at least when he
was there it seems to have gone downhill
since then and now he's running for
president he's a best-selling author you
know very impressive guy I just love the
idea that for Vivek his kind of Doom
scrolling you know in his free time is
that he's just on LinkedIn it's very
professional responsible social media
app and he was kicked off allegedly for
spreading misinformation here's why he
was kicked off I was a bit surprised to
get an email noting that my LinkedIn
account had been shut down I wondered
why because actually a number of friends
texted me saying they followed me on
LinkedIn that's how they keep up they
weren't able to find me anymore
and so when I had my team get in touch
with LinkedIn here's the response that
we got I'm not kidding I'm reading from
this apparently my third strike was to
say this the climate agenda is a lie
fossil fuels are a requirement for human
prosperity
those are my three strikes that got me
censored on LinkedIn now it's it's kind
of funny and
LinkedIn doesn't matter obviously as
much as Twitter or
Google or YouTube or or Facebook though
LinkedIn is owned by Microsoft so we're
talking about a very big company and it
shows you okay they think they can go
after Vivek right now because he doesn't
have as much name recognition and and so
it they'll get less pushback than if
they went after Trump or DeSantis and
okay it's just this one
think about how early we are in the race
though and already you're seeing these
kinds of shenanigans to me
LinkedIn going after Vivek this way is a
little warning shot it's a little test
shot in the race to see what happens now
we have new candidates in the race
Mike Pence has long been rumored to be
interested in entering the race
Pence has not said that he's running
but he kind of got scooped by CNN here
in that CNN released word that that he
is going to participate in a CNN
presidential Town Hall
a little awkward that they made that
announcement before he announced that
he's running for president presumably
though if you participate in a CNN Town
Hall you are running for president
and uh
Mike Pence has gone now on other
networks and he's started to begin the
process of crafting a message for his
campaign
here is Mike Pence going after Ron
DeSantis on Fox Business
I just don't believe it's it's in the
interest of the people of any state for
a a government to essentially go after a
business that they disagreed with on a
political issue I disagree with Florida
moving against uh Walt Disney I disagree
with California moving against Walgreens
because they're going to obey the law
about a board of patience in some 20
States so they're going to cancel 120
million dollar project look at the end
of the day the business of America is
business and and I'm not terribly
surprised to see Disney canceling a
billion dollar contract it's on that's
only going to harm people in the Orlando
and Florida area and and it's one more
reason why uh well as a limited
government conservative uh I've said for
months now that I I think both sides
ought to stand down take the victory for
parents rights in the legislature and
move on
so this message is probably not going to
resonate with a lot of people at least
not right now the GOP base seems to be
pretty eager for
an aggressive response to the cultural
war that the libs have been waging
especially when we're talking about
Disney down in Florida or Bud Light or
Target or any of these other companies
and Mike Pence is offering a
fairly contrarian argument here he's
saying look the business of America is
business that's a line from Calvin
Coolidge it's in the business of
America's business we don't really want
to antagonize business too much we we
want to be social conservatives we want
to defend our values but we don't want
to just Pummel these businesses into the
ground wait you know and and Ronda
Santos he went too far here this is a
message that to some degree is is being
put forward by President Trump the
difference is that Trump is such a
belligerent cultural figure that he he
somewhat probably uniquely can make both
of those arguments at the same time out
of the one side of his mouth he can say
Mexicans are rapists and murderers and
we've got to deport everybody and then
out of the other side he can say all
right we need to make a deal and bring
the temperature down a little bit and
the other candidates are falling down on
one side or the other so DeSantis is
falling down very much on the we're
going to Pummel Disney into the ground
side of things and Mike Pence here is
trying to carve out a new space for
himself in the race and he's saying look
I'm the pro-business guy I'm the Calvin
Coolidge Republican I am the return to
normalcy that's his argument and it's a
little bit of a long shot argument right
now just judging from where the GOP base
is but I think it's not the craziest
idea for a campaign in that you've got
Trump running As Trump
you've got DeSantis running As Trump 2.0
so they're both running in the Trump
Lane which is it which is a kind of old
right
anti-globalism to some degree anti-free
trade Pat Buchanan kind of right wing
then you've got Vivek he's the outsider
candidate then you've got Nikki Haley
and Tim Scott they're running a little
bit more of a Centrist moderate campaign
and Mike Pence is going to run on a
return to normalcy people are going to
mock it he's not doing great in the
polls right now Joe Biden however ran
the return to normalcy campaign and the
return to normalcy campaign worked out
relatively well for him along with the
institutional advantages that the
Democrats had all of that said though
before we get into mailbag Quinnipiac
poll is out
Trump is
absolutely destroying this primary right
now and I know it's early and we've just
got these new candidates into the race
even within the last week we've seen the
entrance of Tim Scott Rhonda santis and
it would seem Mike Pence but it is not
even close so Quinnipiac which is a
fairly well respected polling Outlet
they say that in May Trump is at 56
percent the scientist is at 25 none of
the other candidates are even close
that means that Trump is up 31 points
over DeSantis and that's from the
Quinnipiac poll you've seen this
reflected in other polls with even wider
margins sometimes
now the reason that number matters is
that it's going in the right direction
for Trump in March Trump was only up 14
points on DeSantis it was 47-33 back in
February Trump was only up six points on
DeSantis so now maybe that DeSantis is
officially in the race maybe this will
give him a big move to be able to weaken
Trump and then that'll benefit all of
the other candidates but as of right now
this is Far and Away Trump's race to
lose my favorite comment yesterday is
from Buck French what a name who says
with the economy in shambles boycotting
has never been easier it's true that's
very true when the economy is very shaky
and you've got hyper inflation and
you've got wages stagnating and you've
got seven percent interest rates so
people can't afford to buy a new home or
move or do much of anything that is a
great time to boycott companies because
people don't really have the money to go
shop at these companies anyway we've now
arrived at my favorite time of the week
when I get to hear from you in the
mailbag this mailbag is sponsored by
Pure Talk go to puretalk.com
for your free Samsung Galaxy when you
sign up for unlimited talk text and
unlimited data
take it away
hello Michael
I'd firstly like to start off by saying
I'm a huge fan of the show good work but
my question is
on the subject of Pride and it being a
sin
um
I definitely agree that pride is a sin
however when it comes to
talking about being proud of say your
achievements or if you are a parent and
you're proud of your child's
achievements like say your child painted
something
um that's quite beautiful and you were
proud of your child for that work of art
with that
be the same type of Pride would that be
still be a sin or
um or what I would say to that in my
head kind of right now is no it is not
but perhaps pride is not the the word to
use there I just would like to know
what's your thoughts on that are thank
you
a really good question and in part this
confusion is caused by the limitations
of language especially the English
language here because we use the same
word pride to mean a number of different
things that are somewhat related but are
distinct pride is excessive love of
oneself and one's own qualities and
achievements
so pride is necessarily excessive there
is a a proper Kind of Love of oneself
without which we cannot love our
neighbor properly because we we are
called to love our neighbor as ourselves
if you hate yourself you're going to
hate your neighbor that's not gonna be
good for anybody
there is a proper love of one's
uh
achievements and characteristics and
family and Nation right when you say I'm
proud to be an American you're not
saying I'm I'm embracing the deadliest
of the seven deadly sins you're saying
that I love my country and the love of
country patriotism is an extension of
filial piety which is totally proper so
that that's all uh perfectly fine but
it's the excessiveness and if there's
one word that I could use to describe
pride month and the pride movement it
would probably be excessive decadent
would be another word as well but but
having a proper love of yourself in your
country the end of your kids and
whatever that's that's all perfectly
fine the trick here and I'm not the
first to say it is is not to think less
of yourself it's to think of yourself
less next question
hi Michael this is Dave debunion6 in
your chat as this non-catholic's
favorite Catholic I was wondering if you
could maybe uh either clarify or expand
upon uh something you've said previously
regarding I believe you've called it the
so-called exception uh passage in
Matthew 5 32. I don't presume to know
what Bible translation that you might
read out of I'm going to take a guess of
it maybe you use the do a Rhymes but I
say to you that who whatsoever shall put
away his wife accepting the cause of
fornication uh make a third to commit
adultery from The Vulgate from which
that is my understanding uh translated
probably be pronouncing these wrongs but
it's except the foreign
would be it appears that Jesus is giving
some exception here
um so I was wondering if that is not
because of adultery or fornication what
it is that you would view as the
exception so um thank you for all that
you do all you guys and everybody at the
daily wire and God bless and I look
forward to hearing your answer thank you
really a really good question so what
this refers to is the acceptive clause
in the gospel of Saint Matthew where
Christ says what God has joined let no
man separate yes Moses told you divorce
was okay in some cases but I'm telling
you from the beginning it was not so and
when men and women come together in
marriage they become one flesh and they
shouldn't separate and in the gospel of
Saint Matthew it says except for
except for fornication run Chastity or
sometimes it's translated as adultery or
this that sexual immorality okay
um in recent centuries some Protestants
have looked at this clause and said okay
this means that divorce is okay in some
circumstances that is not the
understanding of historical Christianity
obviously the Catholic church or the
Eastern Orthodox or or some Protestants
too so the question that I would begin
with here
is not why do you
Catholics
hold to and I'm not accusing you of
doing this I think you're obviously very
open-minded on this question but some
people I think will look at this
question and say haha see there's the
exception good why do you Catholics deny
that exception or Eastern Orthodox or
traditional kind of Christians why do
you deny that exception see there is my
excuse to be able to get a divorce
I wouldn't look at it that way I would
begin with just this question huh
why is there that acceptive Clause there
where does that come from Why did
Christians not think this meant that you
could get divorced for the vast majority
of the history of Christianity why in
some recent centuries have people ceased
upon that where does that come from
when you look at that context then you
have to look at the other gospels too
there are parallel passages in the
gospel of Saint Mark in the gospel of
Saint Luke and yet those other gospels
do not include the acceptive Clause just
says what God has joined letting no man
separate okay in the writing of Saint
Paul and the Epistles First Corinthians
and letter to the Romans
you don't see this acceptive Clause just
says no you can't get divorced
don't don't put away your wife don't do
it don't split up so why is it just here
in the gospel of Saint Matthew I don't
know for sure no one really knows for
sure but some explanations for that have
been that Saint Matthew is writing for a
primarily Jewish audience
Mark and Luke writing for the broader
Greco-Roman world
and you might think this is even
stranger because those pagans are a
little bit looser about sexual things so
why would this not include the acceptive
Clause here and one explanation that
seems at least plausible if not likely
to me is that the reason here
in Saint Matthew is that it gets to a
controversy between the school of hilal
and I forget the name of the other
school uh in ancient Judaism which is
over exactly what the grounds for
divorce could be and so the acceptive
Clause would be a way to sidestep this
controversy whether divorce was okay in
all cases or only okay in the case of
fornication to say okay I'm putting that
question aside for a second here and
telling you about what marriage is
broadly that's one explanation for it
another explanation for it could be that
the gospel of Saint Matthew is writing
for this audience that would have
understood uh matters of marriage in
this particular way with this particular
kind kind of language and and then more
broadly and I think this applies
especially today and has been understood
by Christianity for 2000 years is that
it is making clear that a marriage is
only a marriage if it's valid so there
is uh
unchastity poor day uh uh adultery that
will render a marriage null because the
marriage couldn't have been valid in the
first place namely if someone is already
married and then marries again
can that husband and second wife split
up well yes they weren't they weren't
validly married in the first place and
you see this happen
often in the modern world actually that
someone could be secretly hiding a wife
or something like that or could have
withheld something from the spouse
before marriage that would have rendered
the marriage no so when when Christ says
in the gospel of Saint Matthew any man
who divorces his wife except for
adultery or except for fornication or
pornaya
makes his wife an adulteress that that
is literally true because what we're
saying what what our Lord would be
saying is
she's already an adulteress or you're
already an adulterer you're already
committing adultery
in this case so it's it's very precise
technical language those are I don't
know that's like three possible
explanations for it
um but this isn't just a way to kind of
weasel out of the question or anything
like that I think that the people who
defend the acceptive Clause one have to
explain why it wasn't accepted for
well over a millennium you know for in
many centuries after a millennium but
then also I think they have to explain
the parallel passage in Mark the
parallel passage in Luke First
Corinthians and Romans I think they have
to explain the overwhelming majority of
the evidence in the scripture which say
which says that divorce is no bueno and
I think that the traditional explanation
is just more persuasive okay next one
a smokey Mike it's daily grinch here
with a quick question for you about our
Second Amendment rights so according to
the Second Amendment we have the right
to a well-regulated militia being
necessary to the security of a free
state and the right of the people to
keep him bear arms shall not be
infringed
so regarding the Second Amendment
my question is how do states believe
that they can infringe upon our rights
and make gun laws restricting those
rights when in article 6 paragraph two
of the Constitution of the Constitution
that establishes the supremacy clause
which says
federal laws and amendments take
precedence over the state laws
I just don't see how States believe that
they can infringe upon our Second
Amendment rights and make these just
outrageous laws restricting our gun
ownership love to hear your answer
because we're not governed by an old
piece of parchment is the is the problem
but but just the reality in no State
really is
so the that old piece of parchment has
to be embodied and institutionalized in
in Tradition and in state law and in
institutions and in practices and so
that creates a disconnect between the
capital c Constitution which supposedly
governs our country and the lowercase C
Constitution that we embody every single
day and the lowercase Constitution
in many ways violates the capital c
Constitution and we've just all kind of
accommodated that because that's the way
governments go so why do they do it
because they can and we can complain
about it but that's the way that states
have always acted and so it's it's
incumbent upon us to just try to fix the
lowercase C Constitution one to bring it
in closer alignment with the capital c
Constitution and two more broadly just
to make it better and more more
conducive to flourishing okay next
question
and Michael loved the show long time
Watcher here thank you for everything
you do so my name is David I'm 25 and uh
I'm a homosexual not a not a practicing
one I mean I I'm Jewish so of course I
won't be getting married uh you know if
I were bisexual I could just marry a
woman but I'm not so I don't want to do
that to some poor lady who deserves
someone who's attracted to her so my
question for you is how can I live a
fulfilling and meaningful life knowing
that I will never have a marriage and
I'll never start a family of my own
thanks again
really good question sorry that you're
dealing with this difficulty many people
are dealing with it though and you seem
to have a good head on your shoulders
and you're you know really viewing this
through your reason and trying to to
bring your will in accord with your
reason
I wouldn't totally write off marriage in
that I I agree it would be wrong to
deceive a woman and pretend you're
really attracted to her when when in
fact you're not but if you could be
somewhat honest about this issue and you
say look I have this issue of sexual
attraction but uh life is about more
than physical attraction and I want a
family and I want to live a more
traditional life and I want kids and all
the rest of it and uh could you accept
me you know to a woman I don't know
maybe a woman could do that I it'd be a
hard sell there's no question about it
but but maybe you could do that and then
two
on on this issue that you're Jewish so I
can't I can't give you
a really sophisticated religious advice
here because I just don't I don't know
really how this works in Judaism uh but
the in the Christian view of things is
that you don't need to get married to
have a totally fulfilling life and that
you can
you can consecrate yourself in your
singlehood to God and people can do that
in religious life you know you could
become a nun or a priest or a brother
something like that and say look I maybe
I'm not attracted to women but I I'm
going to be a celibate and I'm just I'm
going to sublimate my desires straight
to God who's the source and Summit of
all of our desire or you don't need to
join a religious order you could just
consecrate your singlehood and say okay
I'm going to live a single life one
thing I would recommend though is
uh I would recommend that I would
recommend obviously grinding all of your
uh desire and
purpose in God I would also recommend
being very involved in your community
you know you we live in an age in which
people are all feeling isolated and
alienated from society and Community has
broken down
and this is bad for everybody but it's
especially bad for people who are not
going to get married who are not going
to have kids who are not especially bad
for people who
don't fit into this very
cookie cutter kind of idea of what life
is that has taken hold especially in
modernity
so I'd recommend you know your political
animal your social animal
you've got to be around people even if
that means you're not around a wife but
I think you have multiple options
available to you and and the modern left
wants to say that well if you don't just
pursue all of your sexual desires you
know whatever they may be and however
they may change then you're going to
live a terrible life of repression and
sadness but that that obviously is not
true and I think that you're more likely
to live a life of sadness if you if you
don't follow your reason you know some
people through their reason will
conclude well this uh heterodox thing
that I want to do is
um is is acceptable and good and they're
probably probably wrong about that but
at least you know they're honestly
following their lights uh but but you're
a little different you're saying No this
is how I want to behave and how I how I
want to live and my appetites are
telling me differently well okay pursue
the reason because the reason is
supposed to mediate between the lower
will and the Divine reason okay it's
fake headline Friday baby
member block begins now the segment to
remember go on over to dailywire.com
Knowles use code nulls for checkout and
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign